Hello my name is Trick. I play Jungle on G2.
I played a similar game to League of Legends
I wanted to try a new one. I tried it in season one, last season
I just enjoyed it. Season two and three I only solo queued.
Season two I played so good, so I thought
I can be a good pro gamer so I
wanted to try pro gaming.
My parents don't like the game, but after I
joined CJ, then my parents were proud of me.
They see Trick in the lineup right now and they're thinking alright new guy
you're not getting the Rek'Sai and
you're going to have to play against an
invisible jungler.
I did a test, the test was over and 30 days after the CJ coach said come to the gaming house.
I scrimmed and played good and I
joined CJ.
My favorite teammates, MadLife, Max and Helper. I miss them.
After I ended the contract in CJ, I had many offers.
But I didn't want to sub because I already subbed for one year. So, G2 was a good team.
I saw every team solo queueing.
G2 is high rank, so I go G2.
and honestly if you're a starting
jungler and you need to learn
something about jungle efficiency you
need to follow what Tric k does because
somehow he always smoothly transitions
through the game. He almost never falls behind.
I feel like, good because a before I am
just a sub now I'm a starter, MVP
this split, I had most, MVP.
If I have many MVPs I get many compliments.
I don't feel pressure because
of MSI.
I can't think about summer split. After MSI I improved much.
Mithy is the main shotcaller, but sometimes I can shotcall.
Normally Mithy is the main shotcaller, but I can otherwise.
In the back end, Kobbe dies as Expect
completes his teleporting.
Now Wunder is running for his life. Trashy's running can't dodge the ice barrel
It's a double kill for Trick.
I just want to win Worlds. I think it would be good. We're first place.
Oh yeah I feel like good, I want to go to the finals.
My goal is to go to the finals.
If we're lucky, I just want to win Worlds. Yeah, win Worlds.